hey everybody welcome to another great
episode I don't know if it's great or
not yet but welcome to another episode
who riff from with Griffin
I'm your host Eric Griffin we're here at
the all things comedy studio and before
I play titted this week's theme song cuz
it's another good one I mean I really
appreciate you guys sitting in these
theme songs I'm trying to find the
perfect one and so we're just gonna keep
battle until we find a perfect one but
before I do that I want to introduce one
of my favorite people in the whole wide
world she was on I'm dying up here with
me he was he did a movie with Jackie
Chan one of my favorites what was it
called
a forbidden from bidding kingdom dude up
for the the handsome the the Robert De
Niro of art of our age Michael how do
you say your [ __ ] name angry on I
always say his name wrong angry on Oh
Ardsley we've known each other for years
I don't three to have four years come on
what is he argh argh Riano you've got it
right before I have I'm knocking it I'm
not gonna correct oh my god anger anger
ah no it's okay Michael angry now I
don't know if you watch the show my
podcast you probably don't cuz you too
bougie to watch my podcast but I've seen
clips okay well I've been trying to find
a theme song so people been sitting in
great theme songs right so other times I
sing on them or I do you know but here's
one of them right now so if you want to
join me you can but this is another
great theme song I have all the
information of this great artist and
producer but here it is
oh this was this was a little funky
style
[Music]
ukulele riff demography yeah yeah ristin
wiig Rafi
we got my ankle hungry huh no this is
like going in a direction I don't even
know interesting progression
I like it though right yeah it makes you
want to move your hips a little bit okay
all right that's gonna be good right
that's impressive
isn't that something really impressive I
mean I put it out there cuz what
happened was I was singing songs like
karaoke versions of songs and I and like
changing the words to riffing with
Griffin right and I thought it was fun I
thought I could keep doing it but then
they're hitting me up like copyright
infringement and like yeah they're yeah
they're even even if it's like a little
bit of the song yeah so I was like you
know what I can't do that anymore so I
know everybody loves that so what I
might start doing is original music so
if you know I have a couple of great
producer friends that are gonna keep
making songs for me and then maybe
eventually we will have a vote we'll
pick how many now have you played on the
show I had 12 episodes of the new ones
probably like five or six new applicant
only have two I'm not sure how many
submissions oh people submit all the
time that's crazy yeah they just hear it
[ __ ] all I want to do this cuz I
figured to themselves like if my podcast
gets popular I put their name on this
thing and they're like oh that guy's
maybe somebody's out there listening it
I like I want a song made by that guy so
but it's all part of the it's all part
of the artistic community yeah so listen
man I'm really glad that you came on
somebody thank you for having me yeah I
wanted to have you on I told I told you
even before I was doing a podcast i was
like you gotta come on cuz there's so
much I want to talk to you about but let
this is jump right into like how we feel
about like how I'm dying up here was
canceled that's where we met I know
that's how we met and it was it was
three I mean the the experience of the
show there was only two seasons but we
did the pilot in what 2015 15 November
of 2015 over 2015 didn't find out we got
picked up till like January February but
then had to wait until the end of the
year pretty much till was it September
yeah to film season one because we
finished season one in November of 2016
yeah right so we probably saw
I think we sorted in the summer then
yeah but still that's so much time to
wait
so much time to do a season one that
that's like I've had a job now for
almost a year but you can't see it yet
yeah and so from oh that's what it was
from when it we did the pilot to when it
aired it was a year it was over a year
yeah that's what it was
hey be careful when you hit the table
they got the mics like this which they
need to change we need to have like
floating mics so we can hit the table
goddammit but anyway and then we didn't
find out we got season 2 and this is
like not this is not uncommon that
that's you do was show on cable on a
cable network and apparently like
Sopranos it would take like over a year
for them to we didn't know that was
gonna be like that when you first did it
right when you first got the part where
were you when you first got to when you
first got the part I don't you have to
audition did they talk to you I don't
think so I didn't I I was the last
person cast cuz they called me because I
was on a show called the Nick right the
Nick went through a really similar thing
where we did two seasons of it and then
we were waiting to hear if we were
getting picked up and it was different
circumstances like the Nick could have
gone on essentially but Steven
Soderbergh had an idea of what he wanted
to do and the you know waited too long
and then the head of HBO got quit and or
got fired and a new one came in and then
it was a clean house
yeah they clean I would never approved
any of these yep it shows we bring my
own stupid shows on but it was it was
the kind of that that we didn't get the
okay that the Nick had been cancelled so
I wasn't sure if I was available and so
I'm dying a peer came around and it was
sort of used as leverage to find out
what was happening with the show because
we had this other offer from I'm dying
to play right right it was like it's a
lot of money it's another job like we
all know it's over let us go and so they
released me from my contract but then
that was a week later we had our table
read yeah which was a huge that was the
first time I read the script out loud oh
I I was I loved that table read alright
now that was fun
I mean I was sitting next to like
William Carey Alfred Molina was here and
Sebastian Stan was over here I thought I
was in a Marvel
you know cause like you know and then
Jim Carrey was there and it was like III
didn't know was gonna be that what it
was I mean I didn't know did you know it
was gonna be a drama when we first
started yeah I mean did you think was
gonna be comedy I think it was difficult
to to gauge exactly what direction it
was gonna go in because it could have
gone so many different ways I think they
still don't know right one of the issues
I I don't know I mean the guy kills
himself in the first episode but I
didn't think you know there were so many
characters there were so many different
stories they could have followed I mean
it was about it was about Ari it was
about you guys coming from Boston yeah I
was at a Boston I always said I think
the show should have been about that
from jump it should have just been about
these guys coming to Boston trying to
make it into LA scene that's one to show
the pilot actually popped for me you
know what though it's always the thing
we spoke about the best part of the show
was the was the chemistry of the entire
cast yeah you know what I mean it was
such a great fun group of people that it
was like if it was just a matter of
capturing that we always said that it
was like we all need to be in more
scenes together
because we were only you know like we
don't every time we were on set together
it was like hey it's like the 1c is so
funny season one we were really only in
one scene together what we spoke and
they cut that out of the show yeah we
had this one scene we do a great walking
talk and then they they cut it out of
the show I mean you know there were so
many characters it's such a it's so
difficult to really balance anything
when there's more than like we had 12
million characters you can't do it and
he would and he wanted everybody to be
in every [ __ ] episode right I mean
look at you we've had this conversation
so many times but think of like Game of
Thrones or orange is the new black or
yeah it's a friend I was like episode
like you know television shows that have
a lot a huge ensemble you should have
been six out of ten right we should have
done like each of us done just four
episodes we're not even in it at all and
it's developing other people now you
know let me ask you this you when you
saw that you had to be a stand-up
because I remember him you Clark
Ari even RJ you guys are like we're not
stand-ups what do we do and it to your
credit you went out of
took some open mikes and you wrote me
how that's the equivalent of saying like
oh I'm playing a soldier oh I went to
two days of boot camp yes sir I'd be
like doing a handful of open mikes sure
it for me I was just like I wanna I want
to not pass out on stage I want to not
panic
yeah and I did yeah the first time you
did it not the first time it was like
the fourth one it was like an open mic
in Silverlake it was like in a garden at
one o'clock I went to an artsy
Silverlake holding my like wow you
pretentious [ __ ] it was bad it was
really bad but I actually did kind of
well I wanted over I wonder again oh my
god and then but then by the time we
started shooting you felt comfortable
and I cuz it's a weird thing I don't
stand up yet it's hard and also it's
hard to is that you're doing 70s stand
up or stand up that's taking place in
the 70s so and most like if you go to
the comedy store the comedians you're
talking about topical yeah like what is
happening today it's not like we're
talking about abortion and like that's
what we were trying to do right now you
know abortion and all the stuff that was
going on in the seventies and so and you
even listen to you know you listen to
comedians back then you with the
exception of like very few comedians or
like album comedy albums you listen to
how rare is it that you listen to
something from 1971 and you laugh out
loud and you're like oh that's really
funny
I totally get that reference it's a
different sensibility different humors
like it's evolved now I remember when I
went to the table read I was looking
around because I was like okay who are
all these people I didn't know only
person I knew was Andrew and of course I
recognized people you know but it was
funny I saw you and I didn't recognize
you for fully until it was like we
started shooting and it's late at night
I'm watching TNT and unforgiveness is
like months into shooting - right yeah
we're we're into shooting like and I
kept a sowed ate right my whole time now
I had just worked with Clark on
workaholic yeah yeah we just did an
episode of workaholics and we're talking
about like oh he can't wait to get on
the show yeah he grew his hair out and
I'm like who
cuz this guy I know him and I guess and
then it was like 2 o'clock in the
morning and then I'm watching TV and in
air it was unfamiliar Jackie Chan
forbidden to show Forbidden Kingdom and
I'm a huge Jackie Chan fan and I'm a
huge Jet Li fan right so I was like and
I was like and I knew it I knew under
your face but then it all came to me it
like crashed on my because they might my
even more favorite movie is sky high so
I was like and I remember I hit you up I
was like oh you got a poster oh well
we're gonna get to that yeah okay
actually since you brought it up so I go
to Mike's house and my parents have your
parents house you having a party
yeah I go to your parents house and at
you know IIT at first I'm in the living
room of your parents house and I'm
seeing all this stuff about your sisters
and your brother right like graduation
from college yeah I see like diplomas a
nice picture and in a prominent place on
the map and I'm like wow did your
parents really love these kids and then
I'm like where the [ __ ] Mike you know
and I think oh man maybe they didn't
want him to be an actor yeah and I'm
thinking that they don't love it you
like they love the other kids right
turns out everybody turns out mike has a
shrine room like it's a separate room
just for you kind of like all it's
missing is candles and it would have
been like a room where somebody's
obsessed with you they think I try to
kill you yeah but in this and so he has
this great room with scripts from every
pictures yeah I'm set I I left it I left
with swag they had like the poster that
I took because every time I'm you know
when we do anything they give you like
the seat back of your chair they give
you they give you you know all these
different things like t-shirts and
sweatshirts or like backpacks that
you'll never use but my dad and my
mother have all of them yeah it turns
out they love you more than any of the
other kids as far as collecting
come on man that room is impressive you
know it is impressed it's like they got
pictures frame from every my now cuz
you've been this like this but the
entire wall with yeah yeah it's yeah
yeah it looks like that but it's like
it's the wall is covered and you have
like so much because you've been in so
many things look yeah long you been
acting you've been acting since what
since I was five since she was five 26
years years old yeah you and then what
was it what was the first what was the
first project the very not a commercial
to me no the very first movie was a
movie called aamna Rapoport with Walter
Matthau oh there's gonna be a lot of
name-drop gonna be a lot of name
dropping on this podcast everybody I was
in a scene with Walter Matthau yeah that
was [ __ ] amazing yeah yeah and then
what was the well when you okay so now
you're an actor you're five years old
five years old you have no appreciation
for you no no no I'm honestly it was an
excuse to not go to school exactly when
she was great when was it like I
remember I cuz you were probably one of
those horrible a-type personality kids
too huh
no one of those like you know only my
doctor and know so far oh I don't
believe I'm like that now but as a kid I
was very I was very happy-go-lucky
really just happy to be there yeah I
just liked I liked the attention of like
of being on camera yeah which is
probably why I worked because most kid
actors don't want to be there because
their parents aren't wanting them to be
there raw right right for me it was the
opposite like my parents supported me
and they were happy about it but it was
also I was just so happy good to be
there well I remember I just cuz child
actors can be the worst day I know I
remember doing this commercial where
they it was like I was a janitor at a
school and it was all these kids and
they were having conversations like I
have to do this pilot and I don't want
to do it and they kept calling me
janitor Jim because my they said Jim on
it and I just I was just like I never
want to work I said I'm so glad to hear
that you weren't that kind of kid no I
actually because I I went back and did
an episode of Will and Grace
recently and they you know that I was on
Will & Grace from one
I was 13 to 18 oh I didn't even know
that oh yeah so I mean the firstly
brought you back is the same character
they brought me back is the same
character as a 30 year old man and so
but I went on there and I and I just had
it because it was so weird they look
exactly the same they the sets were the
same the crew was the same like the same
crew of right staff writer is the same
most of the same crew and I just I was
the like the the the the signpost of
change remember when he was 13 yeah and
so I just had this this sort of surreal
moment and I asked him I was like was I
like is it what they say kid they were
like you were you were very chill and
relaxed oh well that's good to hear yeah
well then my and my parents were too
that's also an interesting thing like my
parents would come with me all the time
if it wasn't my dad it was my mom and
then the parents are fantastic people
well that's the thing every everybody
who from and anything I've done since
the age of 21 below anybody who I see
any cast member of director a producer
whatever they always ask me how my
parents are yeah you know cuz they they
were they were not the typical stage
parents either they were just very
relaxed didn't give a [ __ ] well you have
a lot they have a lot of successful
children I mean your parents did a great
job because like both your huh all of
them graduated from college right both
sisters got in your and your brothers in
college right now he's playing you know
he's playing collegiate he's a
collegiate athlete right isn't he but
playing soccer yeah he's a soccer player
yeah so okay then what age were you do
you think that like you really knew what
you [ __ ] you were doing like what age
were you like oh [ __ ] I'm actually a
working actor right and in that you felt
a little bit of pressure wouldn't when
was that my work I mean the first job
that I got what that was like a huge
deal there and there were jobs before
this like I remember I got cast as Tiny
Tim in Radio City Oh God they did the
Christmas Spectacular you know with the
Rockettes and I remember it like almost
as the happiest day of my life like I
was incredibly happy because it was a
huge audition who's really intimidating
like gifted
dance and sing neither of which I was
very good at but I got the part never
met I was like 8 and I was a huge deal
oh so even when you were 8 years old you
understood the magnitude of my what your
well I mean it's hard not to when you
walk into a room and there's like
hundreds of other eight year old eight
year old kids and you get the part
that's like a sense of competition is
you know what were you most proud of
when you uh well the job that I that was
the first serious thing that I got was a
movie that was originally called fifty
violins and it was Wes Craven directed
it and Madonna was the star of it really
and with Angela Bassett and Aidan Quinn
and glory Stefan almost happen but and I
did a table read and I was playing
Madonna's son and like we're sitting
right next to each other during a table
read and she's playing with my hair the
entire time as if I'm how old are you at
that time uh like ten ok guess it wasn't
creepy
it wasn't like did you feel like a
virgin yeah it was it was really it was
intense and great but that that Madonna
dropped out the movie's title got
changed to music of the heart and Meryl
Streep replaced her oh my god so I was I
was Meryl Streep son like good water
what about replacing like some
benchwarmer with with Jordan herself you
know she got nominated for an Academy
Award
you think Madonna looks like what the
[ __ ] was I thinking yeah no oh wow so
you've worked with Marisa day I was like
that I was 9 or 10 years old and but I
had to learn how to play violin because
the movie is about like an inner city
music teacher and who Meryl Streep plays
it's based on a real person who starts a
music program in like a public school in
Harlem well so this was like why people
saving white people Yeah right and so it
was very much so I had to learn how to
play the violin and it was the hardest
thing I've ever done to this day did you
get good at it can you still pick up a
violin today and like play a couple of
notes the the notes are ingrained in
had like I would know how to play a song
I wouldn't I wouldn't play it well but
it's ingrained in my that's great that
is the I remember coming home from
rehearsal being crying to my mother and
being like it's like I can't do this
yeah no straight if I can't do this this
is the hardest thing but that was like
turned out to be a worthwhile experience
yeah it was the it was very formative it
was also you know they say this about
people like the really great actors and
and you know creative people are the
most humble and down to earth and so she
was the most humble and down to earth
you would never assume I remembered a
day one a film a real street Meryl
Streep day one of filming she had to run
in a scene and we're filming like the
middle of the city in New York it's
freezing out it's like January and she
fell on her face
oh gosh she fell flat on her face in the
middle of a take and everybody rushed
over at her and was so nervous right and
she got up and she's like I'm all right
let's keep going I'm fine literally
brushed it off it was like I don't I'm
okay listen I love male Street but one
thing that pisses me off is every year
when she's nominated for an Oscar like
[ __ ] got back to surprise you know what
I mean only the greatest actress in the
history of acting you know I know
I guess he worked with Meryl Streep and
what was next so that was the one you
thought but at the time did you know at
the time though you were like oh this is
a big deal I knew it was a big deal that
was that was a big deal because that was
a big movie and um and I remember were
you worried when Madonna dropped out
were you worried like oh there goes this
no are you worried you didn't care no I
don't think well if I did I don't have
any real memory it wasn't because but
not even a thing at that time no it
might have been like Meryl Streep it
might have been like Madonna's dropped
out but Meryl Streep is replacing only
might have been in the set in the same
breath oh but yeah that was that was big
that was a big deal yeah what was next
after that almost famous problem almost
yeah that's the one yeah you know that's
the one that do you think that's the one
that like it was like all right we're
gonna hear you had like offers coming in
it was
I mean it was definitely it's a movie to
this day that I get nobody recognizes me
from music of the heart you know I write
like almost famous is a is a classic
movie yeah it is recognize me from to
this day yeah which I'm shocked by but
well I'm I'm more sky-high but you know
guys always gonna be like oh that yeah
almost famous that's great superhero
movie was like you know with with Frank
and Wonder Woman in it you know Dell's
my first crush when I was a kid really
yeah Lynda Carter in the Carter yeah
yeah yeah so it's like him how old were
you when you oh man it was like eight
nine ten like you know that was like my
formative years I seen her on TV
spinning around with her clothes why not
so when did you so you start okay almost
famous but like what was sky-high like
your first starring role where they like
some there was a couple of things F I
mean and in that time the hit that was
the first hit well it was the first it
was a huge Disney movie it was like a it
was the lead of a Disney movie yeah
B but before that I did Lords of Dogtown
which I thought was a big deal to yes
what I wasn't the star of that that's
what I'm saying yeah yeah you're good at
ensembles right yeah I fit right in yeah
I truth is I really didn't want to do
sky high did what it was I'm outraged
about like pretentious oh you maniac I
was like I don't want to be a Disney kid
I don't and I was like I knew you were a
monster that's all coming out now no so
this is the truth I actually auditioned
for Sky High when I was doing the Lords
of Dogtown so I had like my long hair
extensions in and I got the sides and it
was for war and peace it was for the guy
who throws fire right right right
and I was like that's kind of cool it's
the bad guy yeah and so I auditioned for
war and peace and the director Mike
Mitchell he's sitting there and I'm like
I'm doing this like really intense
audition and they're like like I'm
crying in the audition they're like you
know he's a good guy he's Tukey's know
the director was like that was really
good but I think you have the wrong
sides and the characters original name
not will strong cold it was
well stronghold it was Jeremy stronghold
Jeremy and so they made me they gave me
the sides for Jeremy and they were
making they made me wait in the waiting
room to like learn him a little bit and
I was like yes well that's that's a
testament to how good you are there and
if you just went to the waiting room and
like and this day energy that you didn't
want to do it you're like this is a
piece of [ __ ] be a Disney star yeah then
you win a nearly lost it off you know if
it blew him away it's the truth because
I was doing Lords of Dogtown we you know
we thought that movie was like the
outsiders so I did go in with this
little bit of a chip on my shoulder like
a very dramatic yes over like attitude
yeah yeah well at that point Woodland
Hills but also that script wasn't funny
when when the the script that we all got
auditioned with it wasn't punched up it
was punched up way later when it was
campy er when you finally filmed it yeah
it was a it was a comedy when we filmed
it but when we read it it was a
straight-up superhero movie with no with
very little humor so they had the the
the writers from The Simpsons and like
SpongeBob SquarePants
but like all your nightmares this could
be is what they did
oh man but they also had like kids in
the hall they had like Dave Foley and
Kevin Macdonald yeah there was some
great people in there it's really funny
peopleit's
it was a fun that's why I liked about
was a funny movie a funny movie yeah the
guy wasn't gay who you're talking about
he's like the sidekick no the experience
of making that movie was one of the most
fun ever none did you learn a lesson
from that did you learn a lesson not to
judge a book by it's cover yes I yes
totally and also like things happen for
a reason and I think it was an
earnestness it was like a authentic Ness
you brought to it that the fact that you
weren't a sort of a Disney kid I think
that's what is endearing quality that
you brought to the role yeah and I was
also a sophomore in high school and I
was doing you know I was literally
during sky high I was studying for my
SATs Oh
you know what I mean so it will pass
your SATs I think I got like my age
don't I pass but I think I did bad I
think I got like a 10/10 on my is a dead
of 1600 god this is bad so you did sky
high and then from sky high you know now
did that give you much more attention in
terms of being a leading man per se or
like a young young hero so funny because
now we're so aware of it I mean you know
getting breaks and getting how you're
perceived but at the time I it was a big
deal but it was also like I so didn't
think about it I was literally in school
mmm-hmm and so when I wasn't getting a
job when I wasn't working there were a
string of jobs after sky high I did a
bunch of independent movies that I was
the star and so that it definitely did
rise something like if today it would it
would be I would perceive it differently
I would be like oh I was that this
opened up this opportunity to be in this
thing or like you know but at the time
coming off Lords of Dogtown and they
wanted to that you still had an attitude
of like West I still want to do like
meaningful work yeah yeah you're all
over that big time maybe I'd pay to be
yeah now like you mean me to be Robin
yeah exactly
oh man and then Wendy's know then you
did all those roles then you got the
Forbidden Kingdom yeah that didn't come
so I was 15 or 16 when I disguise 15
during sky high no yeah it was 15 during
sky high
oh that must have been a nightmare shoot
because you can't you were underage it
was this summer oh it was out of set I
mean so you were allowed to work extra
hours at the time or how did they do
that yeah I mean I was only able to
allowed legally to work nine and a half
hours and you know like one of the
reasons but why my parents are such not
are so not stage parents because so many
people producers agents would tell my
parents you know you should he needs to
get his GED he needs to get emancipated
right which means you could work as it
you could legally work as an adult right
right but that would mean that they
would have to take me out of high school
which I went to a normal high school in
the valley oh yeah and be homeschooled
and I'd never ever wanted to be
homeschooled
and so you'd be a weirdo so but the what
it meant was that I worked I would have
to work in a limited finite amount of
time like they couldn't just keep me on
set for 16 hours so you're so that's so
that without a difficult shoot then the
sky I mean it was stressful in the sense
that I was studying for SATs but it was
still really fun of course you were
filming a movie you're a movie star yeah
even when you once you got past it it's
not like an artsy film there was a party
that was like [ __ ] I'm the star of this
movie it was a huge part part yeah I got
that part now who is being wonderful
would it be the sequel now you're the
dad oh man so then when did not when did
Forbidden Kingdom come around not till I
was like 20 oh sure so like five years
ago you still looked 15 yeah you look
like 17 now what was significant to
about the Forbidden Kingdom was that it
was around the writer strike hmm
so there weren't a lot of jobs going
around there weren't like a lot of there
wasn't a lot of stuff so I just worked
so steadily and consistently for five
years six seven years whatever and then
it got really quiet right and then
Forbidden Kingdom came along and I yeah
got that it was six months in China I
know I love you told please like I love
when you talk about like the first time
you had to learn kung fu yeah what do
they do that you know you they cracked
your back what was that what boy they
they so I had two weeks of fight
training which is literally it's so it's
the same thing like boot camp combo
right right it's so now if you weren't a
kung fu expert after two weeks right
right but day one and this is like in
China in a little city called hung Jian
where we shot the majority of the movie
which is an amazing place because in
hung GN it was essentially bill it's a
like a factory town in like five hours
outside of Shanghai and a guy like a
producer once like a Chinese film maker
decided that he wanted to bring
productions to China and so he built the
Forbidden City three-quarter scale oh
wow and and then he built the Qin Palace
and then there are all these or everyone
that was a historical site [ __ ] in this
city and literally in the six months
that I was there the skyline of the city
changed because there was so such crazy
working so many things were going on and
there's no regulations there so they had
people working so yeah 30 hours a day oh
my god
but like hero was shot there the Jet Li
movie hero they shot that there you know
so it was the day one of and whooping is
the fight choreography that I don't know
that name The Matrix Crouching Tiger
bride right he's amazed like post matrix
but like hot off the press picture you
know what I mean and so I was pretty
flexible to start because my mother is a
dance teacher but day one they they
brought me onto the mat they're all
chained smoking cigarettes my um yeah
they there's a Ledge that's like up to
my chin right and they put my leg on the
ledge right and so I'm like almost like
I'm fully almost 180 and your leg is up
like this yeah it's like my leg is like
right here yeah yeah yeah I'm like huh
and they come up to me from behind me
and push my back into your life into my
legs so like I'm face to face with my
ankle here oh my god I literally heard
up right just my entire leg thought it
was like somebody was shooting you no no
they they tear [ __ ] oh wow
so I couldn't really walk for like two
weeks
oh wow I not on crutches but I literally
imagine like the sorest you've ever been
times ten no at that moment
were you like enraged will you just like
what I was doing I was like I was a
little anxious because I was like I need
there's a lot I need to do uh-huh
I need to get there but by the end of it
by the time I felt like my legs were
working normally again I fully could do
splits right like I'm Bowl split this is
this was the process they knew that yeah
and so it was eight hours a day and an
hour was dedicated to stretching Jesus
Christ yeah an hour and
you would do splits and I would have one
guy holding my shoulders I would have
another guy on my back I would have
another guy pulling me this way Wow
so can you handle yourself now today
like did you learn anything I went I
went to one martial arts class when I
got back from LA it was a two-hour class
and it didn't translate yeah I don't
know what happened but like I almost
threw up halfway through the class I
love you realizing movie come foo it's
not the same you know it's not the same
so it was great working with Jackie Chan
and Jet Li yeah it was it was so surreal
it was very outer body like I you know
there were the first month of filming we
were all on location and the first
location was a place called dune Wong
which is in the Gobi Desert at the end
of the Great Wall Inner Mongolia and
it's like it's what like you see on
screen savers yeah he's like Microsoft
screen savers I was there right and
you're doing a scene in which you're
doing Tai Chi in the middle of the does
it's so it was so surreal yeah very
difficult I saw that by the way I saw
that movie in two theaters
did you yeah that's how big of a fan I
am of Jackie Chan and like you know you
know so I that's why I'm saying I I knew
I knew you know I know I knew I knew you
now okay we've talked about all that
[ __ ] uh-huh my there's a lot of Star
Wars talk show uh-huh Bobby Lee and his
brother have come on we talked about it
Blake from workaholics was on here and
we were talking about yeah
Star Wars and one of the things we were
talking about the Star Wars I said to
him on the shelves like you know I don't
usually like child actors because
there's two kinds of child actors
there's great and then there's Anakin
Skywalker yeah everybody I want to get
the camera on it now here's something I
want you guys to know that my man Mike
here was almost Anakin Skywalker and
when I heard that it blew my mind
because you would have been a thousand
times better you know what what the [ __ ]
what how did you [ __ ] this on you know
what's crazy is I don't think I would
have been like you're like no come on
no I mean look I I thought sky high you
you you were doing
we would [ __ ] meryl streep man it
much better in the podraces than that
kid honestly do not get this part you
know we got that was that was you know
before music of the heart I was like
seven or 800 cases like general casting
calls in New York
uh-huh I was a huge Star Wars fan is one
of my favorite of course and so like I
was a big fan but it was a general
general casting called I literally look
at the camera and smile okay
they were just they were just bringing
in kids bringing cattle you're okay yeah
exactly let's see we could find our
birthday like months go by like four
months three four months and it's like
down to the wire and meaning like
there's 10 to 20 kids they're looking at
out of thousands but even at that point
you're one of the 20 yeah no no I know
I'm one of the 20 yeah but even at that
point were you excited at being part of
the 2000 you still thought that is 20
I'm I don't think I'm going to say hard
to say I don't really remember okay but
the then I heard you're getting flown
out to the Skywalker Ranch oh you and
two other young actors and the script is
coming the script so you're now you're
ended but your final three final three
you get the bronze medal in this year
final three final three and we get the
script for the audition it's not the
script for the movie it's the script for
the audition which is like this thick
okay it's a 50 pages if you haven't seen
it yet oh no no but it was like this is
what we you're eight years old yeah and
they give you a script this thick to
learn to learn and they fly you up to
the Star Wars rant yeah okay go on and
the three of us you know my mother came
with me I think we'd get flown out to
San Francisco spend a weekend Skywalker
Ranch Natalie Portman is there like 14
year old Natalie Portman George Lucas
right everything it's the first you're
seen r2d2 you're seeing although no
literally like it's this it's Lucasfilm
right right it's incredible it's like an
estate it's a massive so it okay so you
got the script you ready yeah
you're working on you're working on with
your mom working on it with my mom my
god my agent probably like it is your
mom Jar Jar that's a yeah yeah yeah
the this audition scene is in the movie
actually uh-huh and what was it what was
it what seemed right it was it was when
he first first meets Natalie Portman oh
I love it
your mom was Natalie Portman yeah I I
would have loved to seeing that on film
you know what's crazy is that you and
your mom working on it tell me you still
had that someplace well there's a
documentary on it you could see like
part of the audition okay you could see
it but I remember it's the only time in
my life my mother was like what happened
and I was like what do you mean mom is
like how did you [ __ ] this so she was
like you you like you were great
no you know she was like you were so
nervous oh oh you were and I was like
maybe I was really nervous but you watch
it and I there was definitely a part of
me that was like very wrote very like
repeating the lines not you just weren't
in it I just did he caught you want
abandoned mine they just caught you on a
bad day my day not my day but I don't
understand what kind of day this other
guy was hey he must have had the best
Davis [ __ ] line now I know we became
really good friends oh you and me family
Jake Lloyd was a really sweet guy and in
all fairness that was one of the things
we're probably so three months went by
like another three you have to so you
you don't even know if you've got the
proton oh no no no this is a half a year
this is six months from audition three
months you're gonna clone at Skywalker
Ranch and then months later mm-hmm
and what's like it's down to you and
Jake you're out of the running it's down
to you and the other kid it's down to
the like every iteration oh so they you
there was times you thought I'm gonna
get this yes like you it's it's it's
kind of like swaying in your direction
now and you're eight and of course your
agents like you I'm sure you know
they're telling you like good things bad
thing no it's it's all my parents I
wasn't like my parents are talking about
my parents are letting me know and it's
or trying to manage your expectations
exactly and I remember I they picked me
up from school and I was the both of
them and I was driving home on Staten
Island and I remember like unbuttoning
my shirt way down and I had a vest on
and I went to my parents I was like hey
Who am I and they were like no and I was
like han Solo
solo and they were like what guess who
you're not honestly probably the thing
right I mean all right cried for hours I
locked myself to my closet and cried but
in all honesty it probably was the
hugest experience and lesson and like it
set me up for rejection swear to god
that's perfect and and six months later
or a year later the movie comes out and
hey what happened to that kid I mean he
was an eight-year-old kid like yeah it
was horrible yeah dude it was just I'm
sorry you know that you you don't have
to apology was terrible like when you
tell me this before that you were almost
I thought to myself what happened like
like I don't know my mother would ask
the same question she's like what did
you do well yeah because I don't because
it doesn't make any sense to me
but also they they went with that like
if these are the final three I always
thought to myself if that guy got it who
would a dude he's [ __ ] actors that
there's so many things like that in my
life that I've gotten close on that it's
like speaking of yeah and I'm very the
good segue mic huh not only was he
almost Anakin Skywalker he almost got to
say one of the most famous phrases in
cinema I see dead people you were almost
a kid from almost I mean I got close I
don't think it was down to me and him
but I got really close oh I I well it
was the kind of thing where I had like
five auditions in a day and $0.06 was
the last one and it was with the casting
director who was av Kaufman it's like a
big casting director in New York and she
knew me and like I've seen her like
[ __ ] how do you at this point I mean
nine ten oh wow this was like oh yeah
you just like oh yeah and then it was
like oh yeah like every every huge part
for young kid actor you were going out I
was up for it
oh man so anymore they don't even know
so I know that six doesn't know about
start so okay I'll come in the middle
Malcolm hearing tested he never lost
malcolm in the middle'
uh also home alone three wow that was
that was a big one that one probably
more than Star Wars where I was
devastated I was devastated I was really
upset about Star Wars
one fine day a movie called one fine day
which was Michelle Pfeiffer and George
Clooney I remember that's a great movie
yeah yeah yeah I must upset about that
to this day a little bit yeah but that
one was like one of those oh yeah yeah
it's not the lead role it's automatic
it's Star Wars and there are more but 6n
oh so IE well yeah so somebody did Oh
cuz I thought you were like it was like
you and Haley Joel Osment I mean the
wrestling like you know yeah yeah you
know race down it was I was really close
because but I couldn't have been that
close because I I auditioned it was the
last audition of the day a B Kaufman
comes into the waiting room I'm asleep
and so she goes Mikey come on wake up
you have to go at this [ __ ] now and so I
go into that audition and I'm probably
like okay so this is okay so now seeing
a pattern here yeah so you went into
Star Wars [ __ ] you to nervous and
[ __ ] that oh yeah you go into six inch
tire like you're so Wow I know sky high
red for the wrong role when you really
want something and you prepare for it
you don't get it oh well you should have
went out for Jar Jar exactly right like
[ __ ] jaar jaar jaar jaar
oh man well you know what it still
worked out though Oh show a sixth sense
they were like he's incredible after my
read they were like he was incredible
like we're bringing him in tomorrow
audition with the director right he's
incredible like to have him do nothing
different and I walk in it's like noon
I'm now you're Pepe I'm Pepe my hair's
gel you try you were trying too hard
missing school and all of a sudden I'm
reading the sides and I'm like so stupid
I think I said this is so I think I said
this I city podcast is actually gonna be
about what not to do auditions this is
yeah okay so then you're like wow you
just so that was it I didn't go I didn't
go any further yeah once you said that
they were like thank you thank you for
coming yeah thank you very much next you
know wow yeah big-time well you know I
don't work out that was that was the
lesson any of those would have done
crazy things but yeah you know who knows
though who knows
oh we're not yes it's not like it's not
like those two guys went on to have like
some tremendous career it's just it's
now Haley Joel Osment is like the fat
weird guy in all these parties hilarious
now and like these develop on e but I
stopped for a while I mean there's there
I feel like I've always been really
lucky because I was able to keep working
keep working consistently and never I
always always hated and resented like
the idea of getting like having a big
break because to me it's like that puts
more value in one thing than the other
and then the journey of your career yeah
exactly I totally know what you're
saying it's like sometimes that big
break is like people don't even know you
know that person has been acting for a
levy yeah exactly it's not a break they
just been around they've done their
thing
exactly okay so you coming off okay so
when you came off from dying up here to
show got canceled it was like it sucked
I thought it was like and I by the way I
want to tell you the second season
organic a you did a phenomenal job
you were else you were incredible yeah
you really were but that's that work you
did with Brad Garrett and I really am
sad that the show was canceled because I
really feel like if we were coming into
a third season I think that we might
have gotten some love I think Brad
Garrett missed out on like a Golden
Globe nomination us an Emmy nomination I
thought you did it at a good grade not
good enough job for that too so
you know it's it's the kind of thing I'm
really happy we got a second season
because in a lot of ways we were able to
the show got a lot better and the show
found itself and I thought so too
we're still you know it's just what we
found is not what they wanted if there
were still issues like there were still
a lot of characters it was still tonally
really probably darker than a lot of
people thought it was gonna be but well
at the end of the day we we were given
enough time by Showtime to find it and
like that to me at the end of season 2
when we finished I thought I can't
really like season 1 everybody was sort
of debt remember everybody thought like
I don't think we're coming back but I
was like I think we are I thought so too
after season because I acted at the end
of season 1 we were so excited we were
just like we thought we were gonna be at
the Golden Globes sitting at a table
together people getting drunk and having
food looking over at Denzel and
everything else like I can't wait to be
in a suit at the Golden Globes doing one
of those fake conversations and they
show on the commune oh that cameras
right there you don't want it you know
you never talk that happy yeah you know
I really had all these high hopes and
like I think that we were like everybody
disappointed a lot of everybody had high
hopes you know when it ended I was
really I felt like depressed and you
know in a way that I wasn't expecting
because I really felt like that show
took a lot of our energy yeah and you
know in it because we're I'm sad we just
I'm really the saddest part for me is
that we're not working together no of
course it worked we have a job in LA and
we're all working with such great people
it was a dream it was a dream so when it
was over it was really as if not only
you want a job taken away but there was
like your friends were taken away from
you as well even though that's not
really true we're yeah yeah I know you
know what I mean even when you work like
it was like we we were way closer and
making more contact then because it's
like summer camp
sort of transcended the idea of a job
yeah really doing which which was also
what was complicated about it because
you're doing a show about comedians in
LA who are comedians and our meetings in
LA it's [ __ ] dark though it was but
it's but you've gone on to do bigger and
better things you you're great you're
you're now
you do like how many episodes of this is
us
did you dumb about five and you did five
great and I know you got you're getting
some love for it you know it's great I
mean it was crazy about that was I was
one of those things that kind of just
happened and same casting directors as
this is not sexually well I mean as I'm
dying appeal whoa what's her name
Tiffany right oh that's great
and so I had an end there but this is
true I haven't I haven't said this to
anybody actually this is the truth so it
was the same thing we didn't know we
were canceled right but this is us came
along and it was for a couple of
episodes and so like I could do it and I
and we're going back and forth I mean
you don't understand this man get a call
from him on a Monday and it's like ah I
think we're canceled and then on Tuesday
he goes and I think we're going I know I
was I was all over the show all over the
place like because sometimes I felt like
maybe we're gonna get picked up right
now because it's like if you gonna
cancel it just cancel owes why wait so
long right who knows but at the I'm
literally on set for this is us and I'm
doing a makeup test and I were like a
wardrobe test and I'm literally walking
onto the stage and I'm in a little
corridor and like in between like one
door opening in another closing and I
get an email saying that I'm dying
appears cancelled as I'm walking on the
set for this is a good for you it was
just one of those things like that is
weird
I know that is weird how this [ __ ]
happened something so I see in your now
I know you're working on something else
to write our you're on like a army show
a war what does that one no that's this
is us oh that's this is oh that right
cuz you're playing the okay I thought it
was I thought it was another thing you
were doing
no that's this is us it's the same okay
cool cool but um no I'm Rotem directed a
movie that that's coming out in March
finally finally that's fun this you been
working this is like a passion promises
before this is when we were doing the
pilot yeah I know I had just finished
editing it when we were this four years
ago and you were dealing with music
right so not funny stuff so like that a
night tell me about the tell me about
the movie I want all my listeners to
know about this movie called it's called
avenues and I wrote it you wrote it and
when I when I was 21 oh god oh god oh
god
he probably a monster I wrote it when I
was 21 and made it when I was 26 and I'm
gonna be 31 and it's gonna come out I
mean it's about a guy who's celebrating
his 25th birthday in New York and it's
set about a month after his older
brother has committed suicide so it's oh
it's dark but it's also this guy sort of
doing everything he can to like live it
up and enjoy it and avoid it at the same
time his friend comes out to visit him
they meet these two girls they have this
really beautiful sort of quintessential
day in Manhattan I'm surprised I haven't
sent it to you have I sent it to you and
you haven't watched it no you have not
sent it to me I'll send it to you okay
maybe this is gonna come out this year
it's coming out and coming out in March
everybody so look out for avenues coming
out in March Aries in it that's how I
that's you you guys knew each other
before that oh wow
ari Graynor from a quarry grinder dying
up here the star over love I'm gonna
have Ariane - after you here for our
call but you know what this is a great
stopping point we can't we had we went
through the gamut of your origin story
yeah that's what I like to do with
people come on we want to hear your
origin story and we heard it and so like
look out in March for avenues yep
written and directed by Michael Ariano I
can't get the name right thank you panic
I think I do but it'll be in the in the
credits thing also you can see them on
this is us and I'm sure a lot of other
future projects you are fantastic actor
and even better friend and I appreciate
you coming on nearest my dearest my dear
so next time you come on we're gonna
talk about all your love conquests
because this man is a play listen we're
gonna it's gonna have to be a anyway
anyway everybody thanks for listening to
another episode of riffing with Griffin
and again if you have theme songs you
want to send me
just send me and not you know I'll sing
some lyrics on them and you know we want
to have original content here we're
looking for you know I said I'm looking
for the perfect theme song and I want to
thank again my buddy Mike for coming on
and this is another great episode of
riff my grandma had a good time when I
say great I mean I had a great time and
I hope you enjoyed listening so thank
you very much